there's an old expression curiosity
killed the cat it's a quick way of
saying that if you ask too many
questions you may not like the answers
or troubles you get as a result
this particular adage would certainly
serve viewers at the John wick series
well ask too many questions and your
head might start to hurt here are some
but not all of the biggest unanswered
questions that we came up with by the
end of John wick chapter 3 Parabellum
and if you haven't seen the movie yet
pluck some bullets into your ears major
spoilers ahead each installment of the
John wick saga seems to introduce more
important characters from John's past
featuring some pretty big-time Hollywood
actors playing the parts while these new
faces fill in some blanks they certainly
raise plenty of questions of their own
Sophia played by Halle Berry probably
has some of the most memorable and
exciting scenes with wick the two team
up along with her very good dogs to get
John on the road to meeting the elder of
the high table and kill a bunch of jerks
together in the process when all is said
and done Sophia's debt to John is paid
and she seems to think that he actually
owes her another favor now but while
just about everyone else who comes into
contact with wick throughout his period
of being excommunicated gets punished by
the adjudicator or zero and his kung-fu
goons we never see the consequences of
Sophia's decision to help John well the
high table exact vengeance on Sophia in
the next film will she be forced out of
her own hotel management position as
well well her mysterious hidden daughter
come into play as a result the biggest
source of conflict within John wick
chapter 3 was the friction between the
characters and the rules dictating their
secret society it all starts in John
wick chapter 2 when John breaks the
rules inside the Continental by killing
Santino Dantonio the crime lord who
tricked John into killing his sister
Gianna Dantonio also Santino could have
sent to her seat on the high table
everyone who helps John afterward is
likewise punished for breaking yet more
rules meanwhile John travels across the
world to meet with the elder who
apparently runs the high table and who
tasks him with killing Winston the
Continental manager to make things right
but let's be real how do you get to run
the high table and just how do all these
crazy rules get decided for a group of
lawless murderers they sure do seem to
be sticklers for regulations moreover
how does someone
get a job with the high table the
adjudicator sure seems pretty young to
have such a powerful position
we're representatives from the high
tables showing up at colleges offering
exciting jobs and rule enforcement among
secret assassin societies and how come
John never managed to climb the
corporate ladder and get his own seat
considering how he's literally the
greatest assassin who ever lived you
think they'd give him a seat just to
give the other million or so assassins a
chance to make a buck the end of John
Wayne chapter 2 features a pretty cool
moment in a park in New York City
Winston declares John excommunicate oh
and the price on his head goes worldwide
after that tons of phones start ringing
all around John and his dog seeming to
indicate that in addition to all of the
assassins John faced already in the
movie all these people are likewise
hired guns John wick Chapter three
continues with this thread as would be
badasses all over the world spot John
out in the wild and try to snuff him out
but as the film continues hardly a
moment goes by where John isn't beset by
highly trained killers just like hanging
around waiting for him to stroll by it
raises a pretty big question just how
many people in this universe earn a
living wage as an assassin are all of
these people just trading the same pile
of money back and forth as each one of
them kills some other assassin for one
reason or another shouldn't they have
run out of assassins by now and do
literally all of them have side jobs as
subway violinist dog walkers or cab
drivers New York is expensive you got a
hustle if you want to make your rent
chances are good most landlords won't
take fancy gold coins in lieu of a check
in June 2017 news hit the web that the
filmmakers behind the John wick
franchise had plans to develop a TV show
set in the same universe called the
Continental the show will reportedly be
set in the new york-based hotel of the
same name though it will supposedly
beecher a new cast of characters that
will only somewhat intersect with the
characters we've met in the movie
franchise knowing all this helps make
sense of the turn of events toward the
end of the film when the adjudicator
agrees to allow Winston to retain
control of the Continental and to
restore its status as neutral ground for
the world's assassins you can't have a
show about the assassin hotel if the
hotel goes out of business right and yet
in McShane the actor who plays Winston
has rapport
he said he has no plans to appear in the
show so will the show recast the part to
keep the character around or will he
conveniently be on vacation out in the
country somewhere throughout the show's
run maybe he'll just throw out his back
and won't ever leave the couch in the
Continentals back room where no one
could see him yeah that's probably what
they'll do now here's the biggest
question of all after agreeing to let
Winston keep control over his hotel the
adjudicator declares that John wick
remains a big problem he's still
excommunicated for breaking the
Continentals rules in the previous movie
and he hasn't fulfilled his mission to
kill Winston per his deal with the elder
in response Winston grabs a gun and
shoots John repeatedly pointedly
aiming for his bulletproof suit rather
than his head and wick falls off the
roof of the hotel bouncing off a couple
of fire escapes before he thuds onto the
ground like Wiley coyote and just like
Wiley coyote wick is still breathing
after his monumental fall by the end of
the film he and the Bowery King vowed to
take revenge on the high table in the
next film John wick chapter 4 who let
the dogs out but when Winston learns
that wick is possibly still alive he
doesn't seem all that surprised and yet
by any reasonable measure of logic and
physics even in a world as cartoonishly
violent as the one John wick inhabits
wick for sure should have been a smear
on the pavement does Winston know
something we don't about John wick
skeleton and organs is he secretly a
cyborg or is this really all just taking
place in the matrix and now neo and
Morpheus are going to team up and take
it to the machines one last time because
this is for sure happening in the matrix
right fingers crossed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]